miss Carlson to talk about this game
that could have been quite interesting
with Maurice well one of the co-leaders
magnus carlsen after a long day
yesterday draw with the black pieces
just what the doctor ordered Magnus yeah
I was it was a right wasn't the most
exciting of games obviously I guess the
critical moments came pretty early on
and then after this little tactical well
not tactical but this little skirmish in
the center it was so pretty pretty quiet
and I guess normally nominally is very
slightly better but there's just no way
he can make progress there was one
moment in the game that we were
analyzing I'd like to take the analysis
if you will this moment it takes d5 and
it was here with without playing rook to
d1 that he could have played Bishop
takes a seven and create an imbalance in
the position where were your thoughts
along this variation and the variation
we were looking at was obviously
capturing twice King up and then Queen's
a d2 after rook takes e1 and the Queen
to d2 were you concerned by this
variation that we we spent some time
looking to see the get an advantage for
white with Knight a5 Queen f4 with the
Queen potentially going to c7 yeah I
wasn't too concerned
I felt that I felt that once my roofs
get coordinated I can even afford to to
share the pawn and I'll still be be fine
all right then just a nice relaxed day
then you get a whole bunch of hours to
rest what are you gonna do with all this
time in there yeah I don't know so I
mean yesterday I was a little too
excited even after the game so I kind of
found it hard to to sleep because my
mind was still was still working on that
on my game so yeah I was nice to have a
quiet day and and we'll see maybe the
weather clears up a bit so you can go
for a for a walk or
whatever yeah so are you you and your
dad working out in the gym the other day
might might you decide to get a little
gym market are you ready got that in
yeah I know I didn't do it today again
since I I couldn't really sleep last
night so I had to throw out to sleep in
relatively late today so maybe I'll get
her
maybe I'll get a workout workout there
all right we'll let you go enjoy the
rest of the day thanks for joining us
thank you thank